ça
bonjour aujourd'hui dans notre émission
consacrée aux dispositifs du conseil
général je reçois le gps ap le
groupement d'intérêt public pour les
services à la personne
le gip et à saper la maison de l'aide à
la personne a pour rôle à la prise en
compte de l'ensemble des problématiques
liées au secteur des services à la
personne
on estime entre 48000 et 60 mille le
nombre des aidants dans notre île il
faut aussi préciser qu'il s'agit en
majorité de femmes donc tout
naturellement autour de cette table
aujourd'hui on reçoit l'une d'entre elle
madame jacques une bouilloire bonjour
bonjour pour nous accompagner tout au
long de cette émission stéphanie vergos
coordonnatrice de la politique des
aidants familiaux au gps ap bonjour
stéphanie chemin alors c'est d'ailleurs
avec vous que nous allons commencer cet
échange la maison de l'aide à la
personne a mis en place un dispositif en
faveur des couples aidants aidés qui
comprend quatre volets et qui permet aux
aidants de prendre un peu plus de temps
pour eux et de souffler un peu
est-ce que vous pouvez une détaillé si
ces quatre volets donc le dispositif
répit propos dont contient de quatre
volets le volet 1 la bourse odeurs donc
il s'agit d'un remplacement donc de
ponctuel de l'aidant par un
professionnel qualifié donc à domicile
vous avez le volet de le séjour en terre
dont qui permet aux aidants de
bénéficier de quelques jours de répit au
village corail à saint gilles les bains
et de bénéficier de prestations de
bien-être aux thermes de cilaos le volet
3 il s'agit de la maison d'accueil des
aidants familiaux donc plus communément
appelée la case devront terre et qui se
situe à l'antre-2 et qui a récemment
ouvert donc ses portes en octobre de
cette année le volet 4 donc le café des
aidants et la ronde de coeur donc ce
sont des lieux des moments dédiés à des
groupes de parole et des gens des
changes entre aidants et professionnels
c'est au chaudron que tous les soirs
jacques ligne vient chercher martine qui
est accueillis en instituts spécialisés
pour la journée ce soir jacqueline prend
également jean marie à laquelle la mère
de ce dernier est actuellement
hospitalisé
après quelques minutes de route nous
voilà arrivés à la bretagne c'est dans
cette maison que vit martine depuis
maintenant quarante deux ans aujourd'hui
les petits enfants c'est à dire les
nièces et neveux de martin sont chez
leurs grands parents
benoît le tout petit a fait un dessin
pour sa tata martin est une personne
très entouré par toute la famille pour
ses parents la naissance l'adolescence
et maintenant la vie d'adulte de martin
a pu se faire grâce à l'amour des siens
martin a 18 ans elle avec la famille
comme je vous ai dit on se réunit
souvent donc valence étaient réunis ce
jour là et ça c'est un beau souvenir
qu'en garde un accompagnement solidaire
mais avant tout un dévouement de la mer
mais également du père qui entretient un
lien très particulier avec sa fille oui
mais donc connu à luz il faut leur
mariage
on est alors élevé un petit peu sur son
canapé inn où elle se repose un petit
peu et donc et après en ce sens mais il
est arrivé au maire
à 19h ya le repas une vie différente qui
nécessite un double engagement
c'est pour permettre à ces familles de
souffler un peu que le département a mis
en place le dispositif répit repos une
parenthèse après 42 ans passés à
s'occuper de leur fille en situation de
handicap jack et vous vous êtes une
aidante familiale vous occuper de votre
fille je vous nous raconter votre
quotidien comment ça se passe tous les
jours depuis que vous avez appris le
handicap de votre vie alors je peux vous
dire que ça dure depuis 42 ans
bon elle est née avec ce handicap on va
pas chercher les causes elle est là
maintenant et depuis 42 ans ben c'est
tous les jours qu'il faut s'occuper
d'elle vous savez quand on a un enfant
porteur de handicap quel que soit l'âge
c'est toujours comme un bébé alors à 42
ans il faut mettre tous les jours la
lave et lui faire son shampoing lui
donner son petit déjeuner l'habiller ben
faut faire tous avec elle parce que
autrement il n'y arrive pas elle a
besoin d'une pièce personne à côté
d'elle tous les jours
donc voilà c'est mon quotidien c'est
tous les jours qu'il faut qu'il faut
s'occuper d'elle quand elle part après
la journée mais je peux faire autre
chose sachant que le soir quand elle
rentre ben je dois toujours m'occuper de
7,7 adultes la même à 42 ans c'est comme
si qu'on a un bébé je dirais de deux ans
ou trois ans parce que maintenant il ya
déjà belle comme elle a vieilli donc ça
veut dire qu'elle se dégrade
elle a comme davantage besoin
de quelqu'un auprès d'elle et c'est la
journée et la nuit ça se passe comment
c'est pareil il faut aussi nous voilà la
nuit également baissé elle se réveille
il faut s'occuper d'elle alors vous
allez me dire quand elle se réveille
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait bien il ya des
jeux qui sont la mise à disposition les
jeux ce sont les cubes
autrement il ya le laçage parce qu'elle
aime bien faire son passage elle a un
beau choix quel public elle déplie
constamment parce qu'elle a des
tendances autistique
donc elle a besoin d'une de gestes
répétitifs à l'eau c'est pour ça qu'elle
a toujours un petit chiffon de la main
pour qu'elle puisse manipuler donc le
soir quand elle se réveille je me mets à
côté d'elle et puis on reste un moment
ensemble et après il se rendort il y
voit là la nuit ben passe et le matin
baissé au cerveau commence donc le
quotidien est rythmé mon quotidien est
rythmé avec ma fille je ne peux pas dire
que je fais quelque chose il faut que je
voie elle d'abord et après je fais la
suite quoi ça vous laisse pas beaucoup
de temps pour une fête bien le temps
comme je vous dis c'est limité juste
quand elle est dans sa structure la
journée parce qu'elle parle matin vers
8h30 elle rend à ses heures le soir
donc là on a le temps de faire ce qu'on
a à faire et quand elle arrive un il
faut reprendre en main jusqu'à ce
qu'elle donne le sus cas ce qu'elle
prenne son lit et la nuit ciel se
réveille bien il faut quand même il faut
prendre le relais comme on dit on ne
veut pas la laisser seule parce qu'elle
va faire des bêtises
voyez par exemple à la maison on peut
pas laisser des allumettes on veut pas
laisser des couteaux on veut pas laisser
des choses traîner non non c'est trop
dangereux
c'est une chose qui change constants
donc vous avez bénéficié vous du séjour
en terre qui est un dispositif qui
dans leurs propos est-ce qu'on peut
revenir sur ce dispositif stéphanie et
sur le dispositif le séchant pointer
tout à fait donc le séjour en terre
c'est un c'est un séjour qui profite
donc aux aidants effectivement ils
peuvent bénéficier de 3 jours de répit
donc au village corail donc où c est
pris en charge à hauteur de 95% donc par
le groupement
c'est vrai qu'il reste à la charge de
les dents on va dire 5% et méprisant
charge donc pendant ces trois jours ils
peuvent bénéficier vraiment de
prestations sur le village corail donc
des activités de loisirs et puis pris en
charge le sens où quand ils y vont donc
au village corail et non pas à faire
cuire à manger c'est vraiment pris en
charge totalement on va dire sur sur le
site un don qu'ils ont la pole à la mer
à proximité
ils peuvent vraiment bénéficier de la
structure totalement et pouvoir profiter
profiter on va dire de tous les loups
les commandes des prestations qui se
trouve on va dire proche du village
corail est justement comme madame
pouvoir elle l'a dit elle a profité de
ce de ce séjour donc avec avec sa fille
a priori et c'est vrai que ça permet de
pouvoir aussi peut-être dans le cas de
ce séjour ou de redécouvrir des choses
effectivement qu'on appela qu'on partage
pas forcément à la maison et simple de
ses joueurs on a constaté que le séjour
effectivement à pour beaucoup de choses
aux aidants familiaux et surtout pas
sortir de leur quotidien il veut
profiter aux magyars pleinement de
d'autres moments avec avec leurs proches
on va dire au quotidien et vous donc ça
s'est passé comment vous êtes parti
combien de jours commencent à
s'organiser vous êtes parti avec qui oui
alors je dirais d'abord un grand merci
au conseil général qui a mis cela en
place
alors moi j'ai fait partie de la primeur
je dirais ça a été fait je crois en 2012
et dès que ça commence et je suis allé
au premier séjour là-bas au vvf
vraiment je peux vous dire que ça s'est
très bien passé avec bien sûr mon idée
je suis allée mon mari on à ma fille et
moi même on a eu deux des trois jours
vraiment merveilleux le bain parce que
d'abord on était bien accueillie
vous savez vous n'avez pas de vin par
faire la cuisine
vous arrivez vous avez même votre nom
sur la table est important vous n'avez
pas le couvert un mail vous n'avez pas à
penser ce qu'on va manger le soir à
prendre le petit déjeuner le matin tout
était vraiment calé on est et on y est
vraiment aux petits soins alors je vous
dis vraiment c'était merveilleux on a
passé 20 en 2012 on a fait trois jours
en 2013
on arrive également le séjour 2014
pareil parce que moi mais tous les ans
sur leur nouvelle puisque c'est
tellement intéressante
il faut pas laisser tomber quoi et le
fait de vous retrouver à la mer avec
votre fille ça ça a permis de d'avoir un
échange différent de les changes que
vous avez au quotidien ou c'est beaucoup
plus lourd à gérer parce que déjà à
l'instar de la maison et vous arrivé là
bas c'est vraiment comme le nom indique
ses joueurs grand air c'est vraiment le
grand r parce que vous avez la plage
vous avez l'âme et à la plage vous avez
tous devant voit à peine deux points
donc ça fait vraiment un changement et
l'enfant quant à lui se retrouve aussi
bien il est heureux est ce que je trouve
aussi bien c'est que la mab l'on
rencontre aussi bien d'autres aidants et
ça c'est merveilleux parce qu'on peut
faire des échanges
là je trouve que c'est d'expérience oui
ça peut nous aider on dézingue les uns
les autres parce que l'enfant
on voit que l'on n'est pas seul on à son
souci non voit un côté aussi il l'a
aussi donc c'est un partage et 1 et sans
un échange vraiment à jeudi profitable
en tout cas c'est une très bonne
initiative que je salue et que je
remercie au nom de tous les aidants
parce que là je suis sur le plateau là
c'est vraiment une bonne initiative je
pense qu'il faut mettre continuer alors
justement stéphanie combien de personnes
ont bénéficié de ce dispositif depuis
depuis que le dispositif a été mis en
oeuvre ce sont plus de 2300 aidant soit
4200 couple aidant et des tuyaux
bénéficier de ce dispositif
et c'est un budget de plus de 1 million
400 mille euros qui a été consacrée à la
mise en oeuvre de ce dispositif depuis
2012 et pour rebondir au 2015 le
dispositif sera renouvelée à l'identique
avec quelques nouveautés sur lesquelles
nous travaillons et que nous souhaitons
proposer aux aidants pour pour l'année
les aidants peuvent accéder au
dispositif répit repos par le biais du
numéro vert qui est le 0 800 53 00 2
c'est un numéro gratuit
par le biais de ce numéro donc nous on
procède à un montage de dossiers par
rapport à ces aidants et tout récemment
en octobre 2014 sur le sud
on a une structure appelée maison des
aidants et des idées qui permettent
également aux aidants de se rapprocher
de cette structure va pouvoir faire des
montages de dossiers concernant les
dispositifs dans tous les cas le gip et
permet aux aidants de constituer des
dossiers sans se déplacer
c'est vraiment notre force c'est nous
qui allons vers les landes lors de cette
émission on peut quand même souligner
que le gip et à saper a reçu le prix
territoria d'argent 2014 dans le domaine
des services à la personne pour son
action leur et pierrot peau pouvez vous
nous dire qui décerne ce prix et surtout
en quoi c'est une vraie reconnaissance
pour le conseil général lane alors ce
prix donc est décerné par l'observatoire
de l'innovation de l'action publique
territoriale où qu'ils se trouvent à
paris et puis c'est le président du
sénat qui préside ce set cet
observatoire
donc c'est l'un des prix les plus
honorifiques y est décernée donc aux
actions qui sont menées par les
collectivités territoriales qui vient
récompenser reconnaître le travail qui a
été mené par le département de la
réunion au travers du gp a zappé dans la
mise en oeuvre du dispositif répit repos
et il nous sommes tous fiers d'eux avoir
reçu d'avoir reçu ce prix qui était donc
remis donc à la présidente du conseil
général
donc on est fiers pour pour nous mais
pour tous les aidants puisque c'est une
reconnaissance locale et nationale de
notre dispositif
alors je vous remercie d'avoir échangé
avec moi sur 9 7 4 t
la télé du conseil général un numéro
vert est à la disposition
des personnes qui veulent se renseigner
pour bénéficier du dispositif et
connaître un peu les délais les
conditions donc on peut faire qu'un
numéro alors c'est le 0 805 130 0,02
alors c'est gratuit merci encore à noter
- madame boulevard merci à stéphanie
vergoz un grand merci également au
nickel cuvelier qui a réalisé cette
émission à très bientôt sur nos sept cac
tv